so I'm gonna give you a formal
definition for the fact but first let me
just give you a little one with an
example if you take any whole number
like saying and you say 5 factorial well
you actually already softback factorial
on the boy 120 where that 120 comes from
is we say well 5 factorial is 5 times
remember I multiply all those previous
numbers along the bottom here right so
it's gonna be times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1
do you see it and a quick sort of look
at the numbers will confirm because 120
right well there's 20 there's 6 6 2720
okay so can we formalize this a little
bit generalize it if this is 5 factorial
what is any number in with a factorial
hmm a take is how am I gonna stop this
thing off okay let's just pause that so
I think it's great in to start I mean
I'm sure we're gonna tackle here right 5
factorial starts with 5 and so therefore
I think is reasonable to conclude that n
factorial start to end and then you have
to climb down all the way until you get
to 1
yes so therefore the next number the
next number less than n is gonna be n
minus 1 and then the one after that will
be minus dude and I'm going to stop
there why do you think I stopped there
because I've got one two three terms and
three terms is all you need to establish
a pattern really so I'm gonna stop there
but I'm gonna keep going all the way not
gone until I reached the end which is
going to be one do you agree with that
so this is going to be times 3 2 times 1
and that's you okay so this is our
definition for n factorial it's n times
all of the numbers underneath it all the
whole numbers I should say and then you
just find out with that Prime
yeah so this definition works if you
think about where is the N number going
to star and if I say n is 3 then over 3
times 2 times 1
and then I've already reached the end so
this doesn't tell you hey this is
something you want to add on to here
this just told you where the finish is
if this happens to be these three terms
well that's still the finish so if N
equals 2 N equals two you'd be starting
at 2 and then 1 and then I'll look
you're already at the end so you don't
need to go any further okay so it is a
bit of a weird generalized thing that
I've written a story about six times in
it but depending on what n is
they have less just general okay good
now I need to show you a few ways to
simplify this and then to notice some
patterns okay so the first thing you're
going to see quite a model as an example
is you're gonna see factorials
interacting with each other you'll see
them a lot in fractions and you'll want
to understand how to cancel them so as
an example I think that's something
numerical and simple like that now of
course we could work out what seven
factorial is by the way if you haven't
already get your calculator out and if
you hadn't noticed it before for the
last how many years you own this
calculator talked over there in the top
right hand corner is the factorial
button you'll see it there but it looks
like this
okay you see it there right so just
quickly check it by put typing in five
and then the factorial button and it
should hand you back on your 20 yes
thumbs up it's calculating yes okay
here's one thing I could do
I already know what five factorial is so
I could work out with seven factorial is
and then I could just divide those two
numbers I could do that and that would
give me an answer I happen to know that
the answer is going to be 42 but I don't
even know what's in factorial years so
how did I wake up it was 40 per fect
okay so rewrite a little bit we just
find five factorial in the way going to
describe five four three years each one
well that's five four three two one is
also tucked away in this term isn't it
right let's write some working that
helps us understand seven I told my
definition is seven times six times now
before I write the next bit what I'm
thinking is 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1
and that's why I have no mind but I
don't need to write that beside notation
for that it's 5 factorial
do you agree this is just a shortcut for
us are you getting the sense that
petitions love a good shortcut so that's
what 7 factorial is I've just sort of
pulled this bit up so that I can
identify the common factor nice and
easily
and as Morgan suggested this 5 factorial
in this 5 factorial go on which leads me
like with 7 times 6 which of course is
just 2 all right however sometimes you
don't get nice neat numbers sometimes
you get algebra however what we know is
a little more abstract harder to do it
so I'm gonna give you a couple of
examples I want you to just take away on
your own before I show you how they work
ok so what I'm going to ask you to do to
each of the fractions on that TV is can
you simplify them as far down as you can
okay don't worry about expanding things
out if they factorize leave in fact rows
but how far can you simplify
okay have you got these what do you go
for this first one example three anyone
we want to be brave enough to offer a
suggestion bracket and full stop what
you guys think happy alright we just
speak about this and I will just
continue to working but the numerator
there and plus 3 all factorial starts
with M plus 3 and then it climbs down
and climbs down it should actually keep
going all the way through n down to 1
but of course on the denominator you've
already gone in that photo that's why it
cancels leaving you with the 3 toes
decorated okay I like this one what do
you get that here it's just can you tell
me what I could um what I could write to
help me start to work out the answer but
I say n plus 1 that's where the n plus 1
factorial starts and then I say the next
term is n what's the term after n its n
minus 1 right and then I have all of the
terms after that as well but I don't
need to write any of them because on the
denominator that's what I have factorial
so I'll just stop there and all the bad
is on n minus 1 factorial so therefore
these two guys cancel which is why as
Paul suggested we just end up with those
first two terms okay and just to like
really what this is sometimes called and
I know you're protective refers to and
is this is sometimes referred to as
unrolling a factorial because a
factorial sort of symbol like that is
kind of like this curled up all of these
sort of different terms
altogether right and sometimes you want
to actually just what you can just pull
out the first bit that's easily
accessible just kind of like unwind that
bit the 7 and the 6 and leave the 5 and
the 4 and the 3 and the 2 and 1 neither
will sort of balled up together in there
cuz I can just cancel those
okay so sometimes you'll hear that
phrase and that's all they referring to
just sort of expanding out like that
okay okay now I have one more thing
that's interesting to show you before I
get you started on some exosomes okay
this definition that we've developed
here what's the whole numbers everything
is fine but my question to you is it's
actually not just a matter of curiosity
it will actually become critically
important for us in period three my
question for us is this tells us what
five Victorian that 4 + 3 + 2 + 1
factorial is but it doesn't tell us what
this is because as I'm Chancellor
pointed out we have a look at this
definition is RK but it assumes you end
with 1 right what does this mean
you can't end it 1 if you start off top
one right like wait this definition says
you stop with whatever that number is so
I guess I'd say 0 times and then I get
confused so my question for you is how
am I going to and this is the important
question not what the answer is the
actual answer is very simple but the
question is how am I gonna work out what
the answer should be now can you stretch
your hand who actually knows what the
answer is
okay all right now keeping it up do you
think you have a way of explaining why
it is that okay I'll look it up all
right let me show you okay let me
explain in a really simple way you go
back to your numbers that you wrote in
your table I'm just gonna write them
down again I think it was what 1 - 6 24
120 yes
he is quickly label for me what these
are which is one factor between that
total etc 1 factorial
okay now the nature of the factorial
function kind of makes for you to go to
the next one then go to the next one
seven 25,000 for you whatever the next
one is but if you go backwards that's
how you're gonna get to zero right like
I know you go forwards I want to climb
back down this way
okay well going from left to right you
multiply multiply by two they multiply
by three they multiply by four
well if going that way means
multiplication what is going this way
move division you agree with that what
just thinking about how you go from one
term to the previous term okay how do
you go from five factorial to 4
factorial you divide by five which makes
sense because five factorial divided by
n factorial 5 factorial divided by five
when you do the unrolling thing I just
showed you that's 5 times 4 factorial on
five so the 5s cancel that makes sense
you divide by 5 and that will get you
back one step
yes I can't what about to go from 4
factorial 3 factorial you divide by 4
and then you divide by 3 and then you
divide by 2 and like all good
mathematicians to do you follow the
pattern and to get to whatever the
previous term was you divide by 1 if I'm
doing my numbers right 1 divided by 1 is
1 and that's what 0 factorial is equal
to okay now this is a great idea because
you're like why it breaks my definition
ok no it doesn't break the definition it
extends it to something that makes sense
and in fact it has to be look from
Facebook one it actually has to be one
for really important reasons that we'll
discover in about Monsieur